desperate to make it into Europe people
climb down a steep Bank of concrete and
waded into a cold river they huddled
over fires and burrowed into sleeping
bags while waiting to board a Smuggler's
boat in the woods but refugee hopes of
abandoning lives of stagnation collided
with reality Turkey may have opened the
border for them to leave but European
countries aren't allowing them in this
is the - responsibility of the Humanite
- here like thousands of people abdul
wahid shivered through two nights as the
temperature dip below freezing he spent
most of his money to get here only to be
tear gas by Greek police pushing him and
other refugees back from the border my
feeling is not good here I hope I come
here for a hope maybe I will open the
door Jacques Attali and his father
created that door by cutting a fence and
running into Greece an hour later they
were arrested jailed and then deported
he says the police confiscated their
money Mobile's vital documents even
their shoelaces Turkish and good people
they are playing with refugio who have
lost their everything they don't have to
give anything but they are playing I
don't know what kind of democracy they
are playing with refugees eight-year-old
EDA found us at the Edurne a bus station
she wanted to tell us that she's cold
hungry and the Greek should open their
border for three days I've been telling
my father to buy some food but we've run
out of money because we've used all our
money on transportation to get to the
border the government says it has
modified its policy all refugees and
migrants are free to leave Turkey
instead it's shifting its focus on
allocating resources limited resources
it says to a possible influx of Syrian
refugees from Eid Lib and influx the
government says it is ill-equipped to
handle for some refugees the hope of a
better beginning
was quickly crushed those who still had
money negotiated with taxi drivers to
take them back to the homes and lives
they've created in Turkey Natasha guy
named Al Jazeera Edirne a near the
border with Greece